- [Interviewer] What qualities
do you look for in a woman?
- Somebody that likes to suck dick
and likes to sell pussy,
that likes to make money.
It's okay if she wanna
get high and all that.
She don't gotta do shit when she with me.
I'll give her whatever she wants.
You really like powder,
you really like the Colombian
sugar, I'll give you that.
You want this, you want
that, you get all that.
Okay sir.
Let's get this party started.
- [Interviewer] All right.
- How my titties look?
(interviewer chuckles)
- [Interviewer] They look great.
- You're supposed to say amazing.
- [Interviewer] Amazing. I'm sorry.
They're amazing.
- It's like we're making
love for the first time.
Okay.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
Hollywood, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in El Salvador.
I was born in El Salvador.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- Well, most of my life
had been with my mother.
My mother raised me with
the help of all my uncles,
I have a lot of uncles, and
my grandmother rest in peace.
So, I had a big loving family.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
My childhood with my mom most part,
the most amazing childhood
but there's a side that she doesn't know.
I was a victim of child pornography.
- [Interviewer] Who got you into that?
- We used to live in this big building
and these girls, I didn't
know what they was doing,
but they was recruiting
other little girls like me.
I barely just came from El Salvador.
So, once I started playing in the hallways
with them or whatever,
they took me to their apartment
and they started filming me
having sex and all that stuff.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I was scared.
But they used to blackmail me.
Used to say, "If you don't do what we say,
"we're gonna tell your mom."
I had a lot of fear.
Until this day I have fear.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- Oh, I'm sorry.
I think I was about six years old.
- [Interviewer] This was in the US or in--
- Yeah in US.
But I didn't know they was filming me.
All I remember that
they had a inner cam type of thing.
I don't know if the mom used to know
but the dad used to be the
one filming the daughters
and I didn't know.
But I used to take a lot of the heat
because they was trying
to get my little sister.
So every time they'll
come around my sister
I'll try to protect her.
I'm like...
I didn't know what I was doing,
but I knew that wasn't right.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of things were you doing?
With adults or with the kids?
- No it was the girls.
Teenage girls or teenage
girls to various ages?
Young girls.
I was six.
I don't know, but I remember
'cause some of them have pubic hair,
so I know they was teenagers.
So, we used to have sex and all that.
I didn't like it.
- [Interviewer] Did anyone get caught?
- Never.
- [Interviewer] Did you ever
say anything to your mom or?
- I don't like to talk about it
because at the end of the
day, I wasn't the only one.
I went through it for a couple of years
without my mom knowing,
'cause I was scared that she
probably would have punished me
or hit me.
And my mom's a pretty scary lady.
We're kind of like the
military type of family
from El Salvador.
So we don't play around
with all that stuff.
So, I should have told her,
but I was just more scared,
like I did something wrong when I didn't.
I still remember to this
day we had the inner...
I used to hear
(speaks foreign language)
Means hurry up, your mom's coming.
So we'll put our clothes on and stuff
and act like nothing happened.
Play with our barbies.
That was sick.
That guy was sick.
- [Interviewer] It's horrible.
How were you as a teenager?
- Well, I was always been smart.
Straight A's.
I love school cause again, mind you,
I was raised in a good home,
but I've been through a lot of stuff.
So, that side of my life
I keep it away from my
mother out of respect.
I never told her 'cause I
didn't want cost her no pain.
- [Interviewer] When you
left home, where'd you go?
- Man I went everywhere.
I started hanging around
with this big organization.
I knew about this organization
when I was about...
Mind you, I was into child
pornography for several years.
And then I joined this
organization and stuff.
So they were all older guys,
but I used to see these guys...
These guys used to take care of my uncle
'cause my uncle used to sell weed.
So, they used to come
and protect my uncle.
So after I started running away from home,
I joined their organization
and they see some potential.
I don't I'm a Jayla Lopez type of girl,
but I know I could get the
type of attention of a man.
So, this organization started teaching me
how to seduce men.
Mind you, I was underage.
So I didn't know what they was tryna do.
The whole entire time,
these guys were tryna
teach me how to go into the bars.
Mind you, they used to dress me,
try to make older as I look.
So, they'll take me to a certain bars,
and they already told me
what I was supposed to do.
"Well look, this guy he's there."
Okay.
But the whole entire time the whole plan
was to sleep with the guy,
a older guy.
I knew any guy that I would sleep with,
they have gold chains, big cowboy boots,
thousand dollars gator shoes, bottles,
narco trucks and stuff.
I knew what I was supposed to do mind you.
So, I'll go in there,
we'll go do our thing or whatever,
and then, I knew how to take
pictures and all that stuff.
I didn't know that's
what the pictures for.
So, my long story short,
my job was to go in
there, sleep with the guy.
This guy has something, he
was the owner of the club.
He had a lot of stuff to lose.
So, by me coming in in that club,
meaning if he don't do
what my homeboys say...
If the organization don't
do what we're asking for,
meaning taking more prostitutes in there,
selling more stuff.
Basically free game.
You can't tell me nothing,
'cause all we could do is go to the police
and, "Look there she is. Isn't that her?"
So it was so easy for me to
do that I got addicted to it.
So, that's what I was doing.
- [Interviewer] So you were
working as a prostitute
at what age?
- I don't like to be called a prostitute.
I'm not ashamed but,
I'm more like a hustler.
There's different layers to it.
But the question is...
I don't consider myself a prostitute
'cause I just don't sell pussy,
I do a lot more than I
think as a prostitute.
A smart prostitute
should be able to sell
more than her pussy.
Just like any woman wouldn't
wanna be called a prostitute,
even if she is a prostitute.
'Cause the prostitutes that I know,
they're not gonna sit here
and pronounce to world,
"I'm a prostitute."
No they're not.
(Interviewer mumbles)
Well because they're not smart
and they haven't been taught the game.
I've been taught the game.
I might get 'em so solid.
My game is worth a lot of money.
- [Interviewer] When you came to the US,
what city did you come to?
- First city I came to was Hollywood.
Highland.
Up on Highland
- [Interviewer] So you were
in LA most of the time?
- Yeah.
That was the first apartment.
And after that apartment,
we moved down to Koreatown
and that's where I started rebelling,
I started running away from
home and stuff and hustling.
- [Interviewer] Your story is interesting
in that you've branched out
into other areas, right?
You have girls that worked for you.
- Well you see, my case is
kind of complicated because,
I have over, I could say...
I don't boast and brag but
I've worked over with 20 girls.
But these 20 girls, we have built a bond.
We've known each other for over 10 years.
And these are real full
girl prostitute today.
Mark, right?
- Yeah
- If I bring one of my chicks, I be like,
"Hey chick, go ahead and
set Mark's dick right now."
Do you think she's not gonna do it?
Do you think I'ma bring
somebody to make me look stupid?
No.
So, the girls that I do
affiliate myself with this.
I can't bring them to my house.
I can't go down to Denny's
or wherever the fuck where you go eat.
I separate my selling pussy day...
My selling pussy hours
is from nine to five.
And it's very stressful.
'Cause you gotta deal with
a lot of personalities.
I knock off a chick.
That's what we say.
We knock off or chick and hockey.
I like to chick in hockey.
I'm a beast, not just going in the club.
And usually when I go in the club,
I don't even spend my money
that's the most funniest part.
That's why I'm Hollywood.
I make it seem like,
I got a bunch if bitches.
Bunch of everything.
And trust me when I'm in the club,
they're gonna be looking where I'm at.
And that's where I get my
girls, most of the clubs.
I usually work at this Afterhours.
It's an underground club.
I've been working there for 10 years.
That's when my prostitution game
started really getting hot.
Hot.
Not to boast and brag, but yes.
- [Interviewer] So you
have high end client intel?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] You have high
end client intel I'm sure.
- Trust me. I have Heidi Fleiss potential.
I want them to tell you is,
I'm not here to try to
portray myself as a pimp.
Mark my words, a woman can sell pussy,
or other girls' pussy.
You could be Heidi Fleiss,
but you can never be a pimp.
You can never take that role as a man.
That's a man's role.
What I do have is, I do
have Heidi Fleiss potential.
And that's what I do
consider myself, Madam.
I never wanna be considered
or try to play the role of being a pimp.
I wanna get my respects to that.
- [Interviewer] And the
girls that work for you
have worked with you for a long time?
- Yeah, over 10 years.
- So they're happy?
- Yeah.
Well you see, there's a
different type of a woman
that I've dealt with.
White girls are also the
hardest ones to reel in.
'Cause they're not gonna
be hanging out with
ghetto girl, ratchet and all that.
You have to walk in with the mink coat.
Make sure they see how the guys treat you.
Like, "Who's the chick?"
That's why I am who I am.
I walk in the club and
I'm like the godmother.
And those are also big
shoes to fill but trust me,
this is my hood right here.
- [Interviewer] What qualities
do you look for in a woman?
- Somebody that likes to suck dick
and likes to sell pussy,
that likes to make money.
It's okay if she wanna
get high and all that.
She don't gotta do shit when she with me,
I'll give her whatever she wants.
You really like powder,
you really like the Colombian sugar,
I'll give you that.
You want this, you want
that, you get all that.
But I want you to make
sure that your whole goal
is to come in and get the money.
That's why we came, to get the bread.
So, what was your question?
- [Interviewer] Oh, I
think you answered it.
- Maybe I did, maybe I didn't.
(Interviewer chuckles)
- [Interviewer] It's
interesting regardless.
Did you have role models?
Do you have somebody that guided you
when you were getting into this?
- My first role model is...
You know who Griselda Blanco is?
- [Interviewer] I don't.
- She's the queen of cocaine.
She's from Columbia.
She was a prostitute.
She was abused.
So, there's a lot of similarities there.
She was a strong woman.
A lot of men respect her.
So, that's the reason I have that person.
And the second person is...
You know who Sonia Sotomayor is?
- [Interviewer] I don't.
- She's a judge.
I'm Hispanic woman.
You see I have different levels
but that's more a person that I look up to
because she's a first Hispanic a person
that's in the high power seat in the...
What you call it?
I can't even think about that shit.
Her name is Sonia Sotomayor.
- [Interviewer] Hispanic females
that have achieved things.
- No, she's a smart lady.
She's a judge.
But my third one is Bishop Don Juan.
Everybody can say that,
but I know Bishop very well
and I soaked up so much game
and I owe him everything
that I have for him.
I just bought me a nice car.
I got a 20 inch rims.
I got my jewelry.
I got so much stuff from his game alone.
From just paying attention
and listening to instructions.
You see, Hollywood gets
in trouble all the time.
I'm not the type of that sits down and...
Then I just sit down and don't say shit.
I'm gonna speak my mind.
'Cause I got my own hustle.
But Bishop is such a beautiful person.
It's that he got me closer to God
and showed me how to move right.
If you do right, right
is gonna to come to you.
You know Mark?
But prostitution,
not anybody can stay up from...
Give you an example,
when I have to go to
work at the Afterhours,
that's who we calling.
I call it the hall of hell.
Welcome to hell.
I'm like, "Welcome to hell."
'Cause you could be calling
your homeboys who be...
This is the type of club that
starts from 2:00 AM to...
If it's money's there,
we'll keep it open till
12 o'clock or whatever.
We used to until started getting too late.
So, the club starts from
2:00 AM to say eight o'clock.
That's when the sun
starts coming up, right?
So, mine is an underground club.
It's no flyers.
It's word by mouth.
I didn't know when I first started.
'Cause I know about all the Hispanic gangs
but there's a lot of black gangs.
A lot of stuff on top of
pimping and all that so.
Anyway, I first started going to that club
'cause I started working
with this prostitute.
I didn't know she was a prostitute,
at this time I was a square.
All my friends she's telling me,
"Hollywood, why' you hanging
out with that whore?"
I'm like, "What's wrong with that?"
So she started showing me.
She took me that Afterhours
as a matter of fact.
So, when I got to the Afterhours,
I started seeing that
it was an all game fair.
We have three rooms.
We have pool table, poker table.
We got all kinds of stuff there.
We have prostitutes that come
but these type of prostitutes...
You have different types of prostitutes.
You have the prostitute that has a pimp,
a prostitute that don't
have a pimp, you see?
These girls,
they have pimps but they
come to make the money
just to take the money
home to their pimps.
Their pimps don't have to
go there 'cause mind you,
this place is where everybody
comes to the same spot.
They could be whatever gang you have from.
But everybody respects everybody
because they know who you are.
If they don't know you,
that's gonna be the wrong place to go.
Cause you're gonna come
out the same person.
You're gonna be traumatized.
So, I started noticing that
they was selling pussy.
So, I started selling pussy.
Mind you, this the time when,
I started hanging with
Bishop and all this.
So my game is tight.
I kept telling my homeboys,
I've been there for over 10 years, right?
So the first three years,
four or five years, whatever,
my homeboys has been texting me.
Mind you, 'cause I do other
stuff than selling pussy.
So, I've been tryna be
part of the goon squad.
Tryna, "Look, Hollywood
can do what you can do."
So anyway, I started who
was in charge of the rooms,
because you have to pay for the rooms.
But I'm smart.
What I did is, I went
straight for the owner.
I started fucking with the owner.
So, once I started fucking with the owner,
I know that I can do
whatever the fuck I want
and nobody can tell me shit.
So once I started messing with the owner,
fair game.
I will bring my little outfits on.
I didn't even tell them
like, "Can I work here?"
No.
After I gave him pussy,
I just brought my outfit,
came in, started dancing.
Started making people that I saw
that had money every weekend
spending money there.
So, who that's who I started catering.
So mostly I was like a connoisseur.
Connoisseur up at the club.
- [Interviewer] Connoisseur.
- I'm like, "I'm Hollywood.
Welcome to the club.
"Do you need bitches?
"Do you need a bottle?
"Do you need a room?
"What' you tryna do?"
I didn't have a job.
I made myself my own position there.
'Cause the owner would let
me, he was in love with me.
I'm like a little butterfly.
- [Interviewer] You created
a position for yourself?
- Yeah, of course.
So, once the other guy
started seeing I had the pull,
they started giving me my respect, right?
So once I started getting
to know the other guys...
Mind you, all these guys
are not gonna let us
anybody walk in there.
'Cause mind you, it's about money
and you can step on people's toes.
So once I started getting to know
the guys that worked there...
Mind you, I started
hanging out at the club
and I started messing with the
owner and now I worked there.
Gave myself my own position.
So, once I started knowing
the guys that do matter,
the ones that got the door,
then when I got the rooms,
I started catering into them too.
No pussy, but I started telling him like,
"Look man I'm a single mom
and shit. I need money.
"I'm not tryna give up my pussy
"to all these dirty motherfuckers.
"Please, please please."
So they're like, "All right,
let's see what you got."
And we built a friendship.
So we build a friendship that...
Now I have the owner, cool.
The security guards.
The ones that pimps.
The pimps are there, mind you.
Okay. So I can have
control of the club now.
So I come in,
I wake up at two o'clock
in the morning, get ready.
You gotta smell like money.
'Cause you see one thing
about women is like,
since the clubs opened at
two o'clock in the morning,
you're probably the club and
you already drunk and all that.
Not me.
I stay at home, made sure
I get my beauty sleep.
Flat iron my hair.
Make sure everything looked right.
I got all my party favorites.
My stack of money, my champagne bottle.
This is a lot of shit to do.
So, I wake up at two in the morning,
get Hollywood up, get in my car.
Mind you, I got a brand
new car with 20 inch rims.
I would jump my whip,
go pick up about three, four
bitches, go to the Afterhours.
Once I get in the Afterhours,
I already spoke to the girls too.
"Look I'm not gonna take all your money.
"'Cause remember, I don't just sell pussy,
"I have other shit that I make money off."
"I'm gonna take all your money,"
But I'm the one doing all the talking.
I'm the cheerleader.
I'm the security guard.
I'm everything.
'Cause if there's any problems,
mind you, I can't beat up no guy.
But what I can do, is go up
to the right person to say,
"Look, they're messing
with your girl, man.
"They're messing with your girl."
So they're going to come over
and handle that problem for me.
But I don't mess with
prostitutes like that.
I already got squared off a pay.
We're gonna hit the club up,
don't talk to no guy.
If you wanna get high,
you gotta sit right there next to me.
We're sitting here together.
Don't let nobody sit there,
come and try to chop it off and shit.
All you gotta do is tell him who you with.
With who?
With Hollywood.
And that's all you gotta say.
Don't say shit.
Don't entertain 'em.
Nothing.
Just have fun.
And just wait for me to come.
'Cause mind you, all they gotta do
is to sit there and look
pretty, drink and stuff
and the bottle, whatever.
And I'll go around the
club and get the trigs.
I'm walking around, doing the hard part.
This bitches just gotta sit there
and fucking just get high and drunk.
I'm the motherfucker that
gotta go out there and like,
"Oh, what's up?
"Hey, how you doing?
"How many friends do you have?
"Okay, what are you guys looking for?
"I got four ladies here.
"Oh, you wanna come and meet 'em?
"Come over here.
"You wanna come and have a drink?"
That's how I get them.
'Cause trust me, the girls
don't even have to do nothing.
All they have to do is just lay there.
'Cause I already got the room for them.
I already got the
champagne bottles for them.
I already got the weed for them.
They like Columbian shit.
I got everything.
So they'll have to do shit.
And that's what gets
me stressful sometime.
Not just anybody can do
'cause the top I'm tired.
I gotta deal with drunk men all the time.
But mind you, I could
deal with that anytime
'cause they have money.
So, once I get the trigs for the girls...
Mind you, I have about four girls.
The whole four girls can at
least take about six guys,
for the four girls.
So,
I bring the trigs over,
give 'em some drinks.
"Oh, you want some of this?"
"Oh, how much do you want for that?"
"Oh, everything's free."
By the time that the bottle's over,
my bitches already know that
we already got squared in.
They're hot and horny.
They're ready.
So either how you wanna
keep most of the money?
Pay the house?
Or Hollywood already got the
room down the street ready.
You see, I got smarter.
It took me a couple of
years to get smarter
and make money without
spending my own money.
- [Interviewer] So if a guy
wants to spend the evening
with one of your ladies,
what does it end up costing him?
- Well, you see, I'm not gonna let no man
have sex with the woman and just have sex
and pounce on her pussy,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Hell nah, I gotta be quick.
You see guys when they drunk,
they don't know how to...
Might be the first time so
you have to take it easy.
Like I said, I'm a connoisseur.
I sit there with my homeboy or whoever.
With the client and be like,
"Look, do you want me to be in the room?
"What do you want to make
you feel comfortable?"
So, it's whatever or however he feels.
The transaction for one
girl might be worth 500.
But mind you, I can't tell
you how much I give the bitch,
'cause I never would tell you.
But that's for one person,
at least for 30 minutes.
And after 30 minutes,
you have to come in and seduce the guy.
That's 10 minutes.
Now you got 20 minutes.
So, once the 10 minutes is over,
the guy already is already
without the clothes.
And my girls can make
you cum in two minutes.
That's why I don't like to hang out
with girls who you gotta give em,
"Okay, you gotta go there suck dick."
No.
My girls are professional track stars.
They get it.
They want it through the,
we call it a rabbit hole.
"Do you want this?"
Anything goes.
Anything.
'Cause mine is some guys
they've been married for so many years
that their wives don't do
what a prostitute would do.
I had this one guy,
I'ma call him Jane Doe I guess.
He was a white boy.
I went to this strip club
with one of my homegirls.
They call it Naked Barbie.
I went into that club
and we got 'em.
He wanted her, he didn't know what to do.
We ended up not even doing nothing.
But it was so easy money.
I just took my homegirl into the club,
and it was about to go down.
It was easy money.
But there's other times
that we do have to go in
the room and get naked.
I've been in a room with 10, eight guys,
six girls
One time we was in a boxing ring
and it was a...
What' you it? Retired boxer?
He had his ring and I guess,
he was hanging with his older cat.
Then he was like,
"Hey Hollywood, I need some
bitches. I got my homeboy."
I'm like, "All right, how many of you?"
Okay, boom.
We go in there.
It was closed and stuff.
So, get all the girls together.
You're like, "Holly were you crazy?
"What are you doing in a empty boxing ring
"with five older guys?"
We go in the Boxing thing and
put the girls on one sector.
Cause' I'm tryna avoid the
bitches talking to the guys.
And one thing I don't do is for
the girls to get the number.
And one thing you don't do is
take the number from the trig.
If I bring you to a lick,
you can't bring no girl and
take my his number on the deal
so you could get money to cut me out.
'Cause that's another problem.
Anyway,
we go in that place, separate the bitches,
have the guys here.
Gotta keep my homeboys like,
" Men, stop you little
horny dogs, hold down."
"I got money."
When guys are drunk, they
promise you the world.
But with Hollywood I don't play.
So, I speak to the one
that we made a deal with
and I'm like, "All right man, Jane Doe,
"where's the bread at?
"You know I got these whores
"These whores don't come
out just for nothing.
"Mind you, these bitches are in my car.
"They doing all my shit.
"They're breathing my fucking AC.
"I'm fucking doing everything.
"So blue don't play with me.
"'Cause I gotta come out of my pocket
"and pay these bitches.
"Just for bringing them bitches over here,
"I gotta give him some money.
"I don't play that."
So, he breaks out a thousand.
A thousand just for me.
Just for bringing them four girls.
'Cause that's my fee that night.
I just calculated.
That was what I was worth.
And on top of that,
mind you, the retired boxers
or whatever, boxer guys,
they break some more bread.
That bread I used it for the bitches.
Mind you, 'cause I'm
subtracting gas money, shit...
These girls, they' cool.
They know that I'm not gonna
take their last dollar.
'Cause they all single moms
and they got bills to pay.
God knows that I'm not gonna do that
'cause that's not right.
They happy what they have and I go home,
take a shower.
Hollywood don't sell no pussy.
Did you hear me saying
that I'm selling pussy?
I said the other bitches, right?
'Cause I know if they
gonna come from this pussy,
at most they gotta be all
the bitches put together
for their price.
You see?
So,
in other times I'll pick them up from...
Mind you, these are the girls
that I work over 20 years.
So, I gotta be selected
from the chicks that I pick.
'Cause a different personality
is for different type of environment.
'Cause some guys who like
the girls to be calm,
just get high, suck their dick.
Guys are weird.
They like weird stuff.
That's why I'm Hollywood.
I'm the director, the
movie, producer, what else?
Executive.
But, yeah.
I make shit happen.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs a
part of the picture for you?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Are drugs are
part of the picture for you?
- Oh yeah, of course.
I can't sit up here and say no.
You don't see no tracks on me.
Look, I ain't not crackhead or nothing,
I make money.
Look, I'm clean as a whistle.
See Bishop Don Juan, look.
- [Interviewer] You have a Bishop tattoo?
- Yeah.
90% of my life is Bishop
and 10% is Hollywood.
But that's another thing.
- [Interviewer] Have you
had problems with the law?
- I'ma be perfectly honest.
As you can see, by looking at me,
I probably had a couple of run-ins
with the law when I was younger.
YA, all kinds of shit.
But I'm not a crackhead.
I smoke weed.
I like champagne.
I have a lot of drugs
around me everywhere I go.
You see?
Cause right--
- [Interviewer] It's
part of the lifestyle.
- Yes, an expensive lifestyle.
As you can see, I don't
spend my money on drugs.
I make money.
I like to stash money.
I don't like to floss on the Instagram.
I don't like to do none of that shit.
I like for people to think I'm broke.
Cause you see, when you met me
you didn't think I was
gon' look like this, right?
- [Interviewer] No. That's true.
- 'Cause I can look like
this during that daytime.
I probably would get arrested, right?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Right?
- [Interviewer] What
personality trait do you have
'cause you're pretty
unique in what you do,
especially for a female.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] What personality trait
helps you succeed at this?
- Gotta be consistent.
Have discipline.
It's like a job.
I may not punch in but
I do have to look good
and my mental gotta be
right 'cause if I'm high...
The places where I be at most of the time,
these guys can afford everything.
Whatever you wanna do, you could do.
But I have this, I don't need nobody.
But I don't think that I can concentrate
if I was getting high.
'Cause that's when I've seen
lose money at the strip club.
Dumb bitches just finished sucking dick
and they just come out mad.
"Oh man, I lost my money."
You won't catch Hollywood doing that.
I'm sharp.
I'm sharp as a knife.
I stay on my money.
'Cause mind you,
if I have a lot of people in one room,
that's a lot of problems.
'Cause there could be just
one girl say one bad thing
and the guy's high and he go off on you.
And I'm a woman,
but I guarantee you I
have something with me.
I guarantee you I got sumn'.
And I have three, four
homeboys already know,
before I get the room like,
" Look, I'm posted up in this room
"and room so-and-so, so I'm
gonna have these couple of guys,
"and if you don't hear me from this point,
"come and knock on my door."
- [Interviewer] What's the
craziest thing you've seen
in your years of all these?
- Man listen, I've seen,
some of the chicks that I've been with,
running out the room with
the guy's Rolex and stuff.
And the guys with the balls out just,
"Hey, hey, hey, hey
that bitch got my shit."
And I'm like, "Bitch you better hurry up.
"You better hurry up
"'cause that's gon' be a hefty the case.
"He mad we took all his shit."
And mind you, the person that
we took that shit from...
Man, that's why I try to do good
'cause that's just fucked up.
I wouldn't want my dad
getting fucking robbed
by a prostitute with
his balls out and shit,
running for his Rolex.
- [Interviewer] But that's
part of the game, right?
Sometimes the girls are
doing those kinds of things.
- Yeah. If we don't who else?
Some other buddies?
I get mad when I see that.
Like, "Damn," when hear stuff.
Like, "Man that could have been me.
"I could've got that money."
But one day I will come across money
and I'm not gonna do bad with my money.
I wanna do right.
I wanna be a blessing to other people.
That's why even in this prostitution game,
I try to be a blessing to these women.
I carry them in my car.
If they need some food for their kids,
or they need a ride.
If they need sumn', I'm
there for my bitches.
I don't like to have
females that they feel like
they could do what I do.
Or try to go around my
back and get my lick.
'Cause I hate fucking back stabbers.
I hate them.
I can't stand women that ain't loyal.
That's why I stay by myself.
I don't fuck with nobody.
I'm not the Kardashian type of bitch.
One day I'ma get my titties
and shit and all that.
But, I'm not the type to
be out cute and stuff.
I wanna make money.
Everybody's celebrity around me, bullshit.
I gotta go home, I gotta go pay my bills.
People get paid just to appear.
Kim Kardashian gets appearance money.
Hollywood don't none of that shit.
I gotta go back home and pay my bills.
This life ain't for everybody
I have never came close to no female.
Maybe once.
My best friend, my shooter,
my Jamaican home girl.
She's the only type of homegirl
but she don't do no prostitution.
That's why I have different friends.
If I'm with hoe hoe friends.
I call 'em HP, hoe partners,
then that's who I fuck with for that day.
But if I wanna go to the mall
or wanna go to movies or something,
I'll call on my little bitches
that I work at Kaiser and shit.
That type of shit boy.
The bitches can't do shit.
I've seen bitches trying
to be me at the club
walking with them fake
mink coats and shit.
To my head of course, I'm like,
"They can't do that. I
got $6,500 mink coat.
"They can't do that."
But the club where I
work at is very unique.
I wish we could take cameras in there.
You would have loved it.
It's the gates of hell.
There's pussy everywhere.
There's fucking Colombian
sugar everywhere.
There's everything.
Everything that you would wanna do.
There's no wives, no cameras, nothing.
But there's Hollywood.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Man, you know what?
You're in my head.
I swear to God.
You gon' have to be a psychiatrist.
I was thinking, "Oh, I hope
you don't ask me about that."
You know what?
The only love that I can
possibly as a woman...
When I was younger, maybe I
had a little crush and stuff.
But my love, my only true love,
a man of the opposite sex will be my son.
Rest in peace.
- [Interviewer] You son?
- Rest in peace.
Christian Rodriguez.
- [Interviewer] How'd you lose your son?
- Now I gotta put my glasses on.
- [Interviewer] Go ahead.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] So, you were
telling me about your son.
- Yeah. His name is Christian Rodriguez.
He was gonna be 23 this year.
He's a Dominican.
He was in New York
and he was crossing
Route 440, in New Jersey.
He's the seventh person that
got killed in that bridge.
His anniversary is gonna be
two-year anniversary
actually this November.
As you can see Hollywood or whatever but,
it's a lot to
process with your son's death.
I'm never gonna see my son grow up.
A full grown man with his wife,
his kids, graduate, his car.
From what I heard was,
he was walking looking at his phone.
Route 440 is a highway.
I don't know the details
but from what I know
is that my son is dead and
he's never gonna come back.
But he's the seventh person
that has got killed in this bridge.
And I'm so angry.
As you can feel, that I'm
on tryna to have my energy
on something positive.
Maybe I can help somebody.
Whatever my--
- [Interviewer] Do you
find focusing on work
kind of helps you?
- Yeah. Focusing on taking care of church.
Taking care of Bishop.
He helps me fill that void.
He helps me feel, I have
somebody to take care of.
I don't have my son.
It's hard that I wish I can know a way
that I can hold them people
that built the bridge.
The people that allowed for
the other six people to die.
I wish I can do something about it.
But I'm just Hollywood and all can do is,
keep my mind focused, pray to God.
But I wish I can do sumn' for my son.
I have a 10 year old.
I got two boys.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you have another son?
- Yeah. But you know, just like I said,
my son, it's different.
It hurts.
- [Interviewer] And the
world that you're working in,
has it changed over the years?
- It has.
For me,
since my son's death, I'm more colder.
I don't have feelings.
How can I say it?
When I'm out working with these trigs,
I used to have feelings.
Like, "No, I shouldn't do this."
But now it's just, "I don't give a fuck.
"I'ma take everything.
"You gon' wish he never met me."
But that's because
I'm focusing my anger
out of my son's death.
I'm taking it on.
- [Interviewer] How many years ago was it?
- My son just died a year ago man.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I'm sorry.
- It's gon' be two years.
I wish I can do something.
Look, I wanted to go to New
York and just kill everybody.
Hey, I didn't even go to my son's funeral.
I couldn't.
A, 'cause at that time Southern States,
when somebody dies you don't have money.
Like me I don't have no
money to burry nobody.
Put that burden on my mom.
She brought my son's ashes back.
But one day I will get money
to get my son a proper funeral
as the King that he was.
And the person that killed my son
only got five months of probation.
Five years, I mean five years.
Young too.
He was young.
What is it? Anamalique?
Animalique?
Mulicanam?
Some shit like that.
That's his name.
I don't know the guy's name.
But again,
can't have hate in my heart.
Being into the prostitution
side of game is hard.
It's real hard.
Especially with my head all fucked up.
I gotta stay up and drink
and do this and do that,
while dealing with my son's death.
Gotta deal with drunk motherfuckers.
Always just wanna use me for my body.
That's all they want.
They wanna show you off.
Make 'em look good in
front of their homeboys.
They are willing to
spend all types of money.
But that's why I don't care.
I'll take all your money.
And you're gonna call
me back like a sucker.
Tryna have me come and
get your more money.
Sometimes I gotta tell guys,
I don't want your money.
I'ma take the last $100
out there their account.
But nowadays, I don't care.
Yeah, fuck.
And you know one thing?
When I'm around with
church, I don't curse.
I don't curse at all.
Yeah Mark, what else you wanna?
- [Interviewer] No, that's great.
Thank you so much.
You shared more than enough already.
- Hey, we know you said
I made you crazy, right?
Well welcome to the club.
(interviewer chuckles)
Welcome to the club Mark.
I'm Hollywood baby.
- [Interviewer] All right pal.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- I'm not a church. Shit.